>> What happens if we follow Tit for Tat?
>> That's a great question. So, let's make it a
little more concrete. So, here's a set of strategies that an
opponent might adopt. And now the question is, what does it
look like Tit for Tat is doing in response to each
of these? And I was hoping that you'd, you know, check
the corresponding boxes. So basically, for each row, say okay, if
you're playing against, if Tit for Tat is playing against always
cooperate, what does Tit for Tat do? Does it always defect,
does it always cooperate, does it cooperate and then
defect, defect, defect, defect, does it alternate between cooperate and
defect? And this should, just to give you some
practice in, in interpreting the behavior of Tit for Tat.
>> Okay, that works for me. I think I could do this.
>> Go.